Bell Prize in Physics in 1965 next his
daughter Michelle vitamin reads from her
book perfectly reasonable deviations
from the beaten path the book is a
collection of letters written by the
physicists documenting his life
experiences this event is about 45
minutes
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Barnes & Noble Richard
Fineman brilliant physicist and beloved
teacher is an iconic figure in the world
of science well there have been many
books celebrating his scientific
achievements and personal eccentricities
his personal correspondence has remained
largely hidden from view buried in the
archive at Caltech or locked in a box
and his daughter's home now his daughter
Michelle unlocks that box and shares for
the first time her father's life and
letters in perfectly reasonable
deviations from the beaten track this
collection of letters is a rare look at
the man behind the science whose passion
spilled out beyond the lab please help
me welcome Michelle Fineman hello thank
you
I first read a few of my father's
letters in 1990 shortly after my
mother's death and one that struck me in
particular was one - - a former
secretary in which he lamented the fact
that he was not a grandfather yet that
his kids were slow and what what caught
my eye was I looked at the date of the
letter and I did some math and I
realized I was in high school when he
wrote this letter intriguing and I knew
that I want to read these letters 14
years later I started doing that I had
copies of all the papers from the
Caltech archives shipped out to me I
went through every box that I had packed
up from my parents house and stored in
the basement called friends family
everyone I could think of that he might
have correspond and began to read I
think I read over a thousand letters and
enjoyed every single one of them I
really I really felt that I was spending
time with him again I'm going to read a
few of them now we'll start with the
first one it's the first one in the book
October 11th 1939 Richard was 21 years
old and had just begun his studies at
Princeton in New Jersey 70 miles from
his family in New York Tuesday October
1939 dear mom I like your idea about
coming to visit me alone sometime very
much why don't you just jump on a train
some Sunday morning and I'll meet you
at the station you don't need pop you'll
only have to worry about whether you can
get anything to eat in the restaurant
etc not that I don't want to see pop but
he'll drop by alone Lots on business
trips so you just make a little
inexpensive outing just for yourself any
Sunday you say provided I know which one
so I can meet you in fact if you're
worried about the expense let me treat
you it will be fun the raincoat came
okay it is very nice I think they make
raincoats very stupidly these days the
bottoms of your pants get all wet now
that I have it now that I have the
raincoat it is hot as hell excuse the
language but hell is damn hot
so is it and the sun is shining brightly
professor wheeler was called away
suddenly last night so I took over his
course and mechanics for the day I spent
all last night preparing it went very
nicely and smoothly it was a good
experience
I guess someday I'll do a lot of that
things are rather uneventful I didn't
fall in the water while sculling these
last two times so maybe I won't fall in
anymore so saying he fell in I'll tell
you all about things when I get home
love RP Fineman the next letter is also
letter to his mother and this is the
first one written from los alamos June
24th 1943 it's also the first letter of
tonight which mentions his wife Arlene
or [ __ ] as she was called she was
diagnosed with tuberculosis while they
were engaged and spent her days in a
sanitarium dear mom I've been sick in
bed these last few days I'm up and
working now though I got a cold and I
thought since a long-drawn-out cold
lowers resistance and I have to keep in
super condition I'd stay in bed till I
got rid of it fast which I did while I
was getting rid of the cold my
ever-present gastronomical difficulties
amplified amplified themselves until I
became conscious of the existence of my
stomach so I stayed in bed a little
longer for that and I haven't gotten rid
of it yet but I go to work anyway makes
me a little tired so I sit down while
solving equations instead of prancing
around when I was up I was in bed three
and a half days I discovered that 50% of
the people were knocked out with some
sort of dysentery
from the water supply and I've been
drinking tons of water for my cold so
that accounts for my being sick with two
things at once it was fun just as I've
always wanted to I was sick and people
brought me my meals and came to visit me
and I took it easy in bed and had a
radio put C's I had taken it here to fix
it and I read a book I once bought on
chemical engineering from transportation
of fluids to distillation it was very
interesting and now I'm a confirmed
Chemical Engineer have a lot of visitors
who brought me things among which were
three oranges one apple crackers jelly
for same pitcher for water chocolate
Reader's Digest book news as to what was
going on at the lab etc etc it is funny
all the girls that came to visit brought
stuff but none of the fellows did I
received your prune things during these
times since I was not gastronomically on
top of the world I have avoided eating
them when I get a little better inside
and my intestines become more attuned to
their responsibilities instead of taking
their devil-may-care attitude I'll eat
them the prunes I mean and he signs that
one RPF
because Arlene lived in a sanitarium she
relied on mail-order catalogs to go
shopping or to have fun and for Richards
birthday on May 11th 1945 Arlene sent
away for fake newspapers announcing his
birthday they were delivered to the base
at Los Alamos and widely distributed
dearest [ __ ] I love you last night I
ate over at TAS house we had spaghetti
and meatballs three big meatballs each
we all got too full and had lots of
trouble eating the strawberry shortcake
for dessert this place is flooded with
newspapers The Herald I believe entire
nation celebrates birth of our pea
Fineman T Wiz from all the newspapers it
is almost true they have copies tacked
to the wall where I work and people
borrowed copies to take home to their
wives
big news maybe I'll get some presents
out of it or maybe they'll just give me
27 socks on the back anyway I would have
forgotten that my birthday is so close
if I hadn't been so forcibly reminded I
love you through it although you are a
nice wife RPF sadly arlene died just a
short few weeks after this letter was
written June 16 1945 we're skipping
ahead now to 1955 he has left Los Alamos
tot for a few years at Cornell and by
the late 40s early 50s the idea of
sunshine and being part of the exciting
discoveries that were being made at
Caltech lured him away from the cold
cold ithaca winter and by this time as I
noticed when I was reading the papers he
was becoming known outside the
scientific community as well as within a
member of the advisory board in
connection with programs on science
wrote him to discuss the formalities of
a pending working relationship he had
agreed to be an advisor for television
program that Warner Brothers was
producing for the Bell System series
among other formal legal stipulations
the letter stated that it is provided
that for each program an individual be
named the designee
whom Warner may accept authoritative
comment advice and recommendations in
the name of the scientific advisory
board dear mister Bown thank you for
your formidable letter describing the
legal interrelations who is the designee
is that me or am i an advisor or what
the hell put it in plain clear one
syllable words please
anyway the Warner guys have an author
named Marcus he has come to my office on
two occasions each for about half a day
the purpose was to get more complete
detailed explanation of some of the
scientific matters in the report I wrote
he is very intelligent and I was
successful in explaining a great deal to
him although the gimmicks etc were not
on the agenda he told me about them and
left a document describing his plans I
made no comment on these ideas telling
him they are not my business on the
other hand my hair stood on end as I
read the ideas for presenting the
material but I kept my hat on and it
wasn't noticed it will relieve me a
little if I can say a word to somebody
so I can let out steam so please don't
consider the following as a valid or
official opinion it is just me letting
off unofficial views and is to be kept
safely within these parentheses the idea
that movie people know how to present
this stuff because they are
entertainment wise and the scientists
aren't is wrong they have no experience
and explaining ideas witness all movies
and I do I'm a successful lecturer in
physics for popular audiences the real
entertainment gimmick is the excitement
drama and mystery of the subject matter
people love to learn something they are
entertained enormous ly by being allowed
to understand a little bit of something
they never understood before one must
have faith in the subject and in
people's interest in it otherwise just
use a Western to cell telephones the
faith and the value of the subject
matter must be sincere and show through
clearly all gimmicks etc should be
subservient to this they should help in
explaining and describing the subject
and not an entertaining entertainment
will be an automatic byproduct don't
worry I'm keeping my hat on
and will limit myself to scientific
advice only sincerely RP Fineman my
father didn't like honors and there's a
chapter in this book which details his
many attempts to resign from the
National Academy of Sciences because he
felt that among other things it was it
was kind of an honorary based society
and he didn't want to have a part of it
and on August 10th 1961 he wrote the
following letter to dr. Bronk which I'll
get to in a minute hang on sorry
alright dear dr. Bronk I'm sorry that
you had to be bothered by this matter of
my wanting to result in my membership in
the Academy they must be quite a job
worrying about all the peculiar whims of
all the strange birds that make up your
flock it was impolite of me to scratch a
small note on the dues bill I should
have written a more formal and
clarifying letter as you guess the dues
have nothing to do with it at all my
desire to resign is merely a personal
one it is not meant as a protest of any
kind or a criticism of the Academy or
its activities perhaps it is just that I
enjoy being peculiar my peculiarities
this I find it psychologically very
distasteful to judge people's merit so I
cannot participate in the main activity
of selecting people from membership to
be a member of a group of which an
important activity is to choose others
deemed worthy of membership and that
self esteemed group bothered me the care
with which we select those worthy of the
honor of joining the Academy feels to me
like a form of self praise how can we
say only the best must be allowed to
join those who are already in without
loudly proclaiming to our inner selves
that we are in must be very good indeed
of course I believe I'm very good indeed
but that is a private matter and I
cannot publicly admit that I do so to
such an extent that I have the nerve to
decide that this man or that is not
worthy of joining my elite club maybe I
don't explain it very well but suffice
to say that I'm not happy as a member of
a self-perpetuating honorary Society for
that reason I have not made any
recommendations for memberships in the
past except during my first year and
have always wanted to resign but didn't
get around to it until one day when I
was sending in my dues therefore if it
is not a matter of extreme seriousness
or one that will cause considerable
embarrassment if it is a matter that can
be done quietly and easily without talk
discussion and concern of the entire
membership I would prefer if you would
accept my resignation and take my name
from the Academy lists
please appreciate that it is not a
matter of deep principle to me so if my
resignation causes you any major
difficulties
feel free to disregard my preferences
but your flock will contain one very
peculiar sad and reluctant bird may I
take this opportunity while writing to
you on another matter to add a personal
note without your knowing it you have
been honored and respected by me from my
earliest earliest student days twenty
years ago at the Princeton graduate
college some biology student friends
suggested I listen in on a course on
cell physiology given by E Newton Harvey
he would not hear of it unless I did the
work along with the others
it consisted of reading original papers
and reporting on them and I was assigned
Adrian and Bronx paper on the single
nerve impulse what a fundamental
discovery and what a good experience to
read it in the original incidentally
they are probably still laughing at the
Princeton biology library at the story
of the graduate student who asked the
librarian if she had a map of the cat
you mean a zoological chart she cried
indignantly but I got it and located the
tipica Santa kiss and all the flexors
and extensors so I could understand your
paper not long afterwards at a meeting
of some kind which Harvey took us I saw
in person the great Bronk himself it was
exciting to me because I personally knew
your work in physics we did not have
that close contact with original papers
the teaching methods were different and
it was to be a few more years before I
was to be impressed by meeting the great
scientists in my own field under
circumstances when I knew so well the
reason for their greatness so with kind
personal regards I am Sincerely Yours
richard p Fineman
a telegram arrived on October 21st 1965
royal academy of sciences today awarded
you--and tomonaga and Schwinger jointly
the 1965 nobel prize for physics for
your fundamental work in quantum
electrodynamics with deep plowing
consequences for the physics of
elementary particles stop
prize money each one third stop our warm
congratulations
stop letter will follow a deluge of
congratulatory letters and telegrams
followed and looking at the file I think
he answered every single one of them it
was a tough decision which one to read
tonight but I went with my favorite a
letter to his high school physics
teacher let's see dear mr. Bator thank
you very much for your letter of
congratulations I'm glad that you have
seen the second volume of my textbook
the discussion we had about action was
not the only one that I remember I have
a great deal to thank you for in aiming
me and educating me in the direction of
physics I did not remember the time I
asked you about the advisability of
taking courses in education but I see
that you supplied me with not only a
good education but good advice another
thing that I remember is being very
important to me it was the time when you
called me down after class and said you
make too much noise in class then you
went on to say that you understood the
reason that it was the class was
entirely too boring
then you pulled out a book from behind
you and said here you read this take it
up to the back of the room sit all alone
and study this when you know everything
that is in it you can talk again and so
in my physics class I paid no attention
to what was going on but only studied
woods advanced calculus up in the back
of the room it was there that I learned
about gamma functions elliptic functions
and differentiating under an integral
sign
a trick in which I became an expert many
years later when I was teaching
mathematical methods of physics to
graduate students at Cornell one of the
students wanting to object to the fact
that I was dealing with such an advanced
subject asked me in what year I learned
the subject
before I could realize his purpose and
how much my answer would bother him I
answered immediately in high school it
was very exciting for me to have you as
a teacher in high school
and you certainly knew how to stretch a
young boy's mind to the utmost of
achievement thank you very much
it certainly is a pleasure to have been
in touch with you again and to find out
that you were well and happy best wishes
to you and your family Sincerely Yours
Richard P Fineman the last letter this
evening was written during his time on
the Presidential Commission
investigating the Challenger Space
Shuttle accident
it's a letter to my mother and I written
illa in longhand on one of his yellow
line legal pads that he used so often
it's a long letter and I'll only read it
an excerpt Washington Wednesday February
2 p.m. excuse the paper I can't find
hotel stationery dearest Gwyneth and
Michelle this is an adventure as good as
any of the others in my book you Gweneth
were quite right I have a unique
qualification I'm completely free and
there are no levers that can be used to
influence me and I'm reasonably
straightforward and honest there are
exceedingly powerful political forces
and consequences involved here but
although people have explained them to
me from different points of view I
disregard them all and proceed with
apparent naive and single-minded purpose
to one end first why physically the
shuttle failed leaving two later the
question of why humans made apparently
bad decisions when they did my guess is
that I will be allowed to do all this
overwhelmed with data and details with
the hope that's so buried with all
attention on technical details I can be
occupied so they have time to soften up
dangerous witnesses etc but it won't
work because one I do technical
information exchange and understanding
much faster than they imagine and two I
already smell certain rats that I will
not forget because I just love the smell
of rats for it is the spore of exciting
adventure
so much as I would rather be home and
doing something else I'm having a
wonderful time love Richard this book
contains roughly 400 letters written
over a span of about 50 years I picked I
picked some of the bigger moments for
tonight Nobel Prize or Los Alamos
Challenger hearings but um but there are
many many wonderful letters just a
little smaller moments perhaps and and I
hope you enjoy discovering them all as I
did thank you
I also went the Far Rockaway High School
which by the way has three Nobel Prize
winners so I got such a good education I
did too
I was less lucky with Cedarhurst girls
and he was and I know that later on the
week they're going to be uh naming a
street after him on Carnegie a venir
that's true I grew up in corner gap just
curious as to where the street is uh
history let's see so the gentleman said
that he went to Far Rockaway High School
and and that turns out that there are
three Nobel Prize winners from that
school the the question was where
there's going to be a street rhenium
Street renaming I think is what they
call it on May 11th my father's birthday
which is Wednesday in Far Rockaway and
and it's encore Nega and I believe Mott
the corner there it's a few blocks down
from the post office which is where
we'll be having a second day let's just
get everything out there a second day
celebration of the American scientists
postage stamp honoring honoring a series
of scientists but but on Wednesday since
it's his birthday and it's the second
day it will be just about him at Far
Rockaway post office and then down the
street a few blocks cornea and Mott
and he must talk about it we also talk
about best places to sneeze cigarettes
oh yes I have read that he did come back
after he won the Nobel Prize and and did
their letters to that effect in this so
I have two very quick questions the
first one is I'm very glad that you
brought up the National Academy of
Science because 10 years ago I was
watching the PBS Nova series in
Washington Richard Feynman talk
paraphrase what you just said about
perpetual honor societies such as the
National Academy of Science and we're
just wondering what your insight might
be to that because MIT and Princeton
where he went are in a way honor
societies because it's based on grades
of high schools and college students to
get into the graduate schools of those
respective schools could it be because
my pertinent personal takeaway was that
he felt he was little bit exceptional so
National Academy science but I might be
totally wrong and the second question is
how do you compare his letters on the
final letters that you have in this book
to perhaps another very famous Nobel
laureate the ideas companions of
Einstein since it's compared next to him
kind of thanks
ok um let's see what I can do to two
long questions I'm sure you didn't hear
them all right so the first one the
first one was basically let's correct me
if I'm wrong
since my father had such a distaste for
honorary societies what was he doing
going to schools which were in a sense
very elitist is that is that it um I
think I think education was was of the
utmost importance to him although my
brother and I were educated in public
schools he was always interested in in
our education and always involved you
know going to see the teachers having
having conferences and considered it at
a certain point to pull me out to a
public school which definitely in our
neighborhood would have been very
elitist so just you know kind of judging
from from his response to that
experience with me
I'm going to say that that he was
interested in getting a very good
education and and that's where he he
drew the line and he also did not have
to participate in in choosing who
attended the school and who did not as a
faculty member he might have um I don't
know um that's an interesting point I
hadn't I hadn't considered that and and
your second question was commenting on
Einstein letters versus these Fineman
letters and I'm afraid I'm going to have
to say that I've been working very very
hard on these letters and I I haven't I
haven't read the other book I've heard
wonderful wonderful things about it and
and I hope to read it soon so I really
um I can't comment on that
this morning on the radio you had given
this wonderful anecdote of his work on
the school book evaluations and I was
wondering whether you could retell that
or tell any other anecdote of yours that
would be amongst your favorites okay the
question was this morning on the radio I
talked about how my father was part of
the school but School Book curriculum
Commission for I believe a year a very
short time maybe it wasn't quite a year
and the story of that is um he was he
was asked he was he was honored he felt
that this was something he could he
could do so he started reading and first
he got he got letters from the publisher
was saying you know if can we have a
meeting you know and he said no no if
your books are good you know we'll find
out don't you know I'm not gonna meet
with anybody and um then he after he
read them he made he made very detailed
careful notes and showed up at the
meetings and the other committee members
I guess we're not as thorough with their
investigations and it turned out that
they had all given they had to vote on
these books and and it turned out that
the rest of them had given a book which
because of the timing wasn't quite ready
when at the final deadline so it showed
up with just a book a blank book you
know blank paper with nothing a cover
and a back but but nothing on the pages
in between and and they all had voted
that that book was nearly as good as the
other books which which you know
surprised him um and you know he was he
was aware that it was a very
bureaucratic mess and and he tried to
stay away from from getting sucked into
all that and they assured him it would
be an open I mean a closed bid and and
you know everybody would be considered
and it was really up to the quality of
the textbooks and and it it all fell
apart at the last minute you know they
didn't have enough money and they opened
up the bids in front of everyone and you
know
just chose kind of a random based well
not random based on the price and so it
was very upsetting for him and I think
with he was very busy as well he was he
was lecturing to the the freshmen and
then later the sophomore classes at Cal
Tech doing his Fineman lectures on
physics which took quite a lot of time
to prepare as I understand and so he he
reluctantly resigned I mean I think he
was hoping to kind of overhaul the whole
the whole system but he just didn't have
enough hours in the day
so he did he did evaluate some science
textbooks a few years later and and his
notes on those are in this book where
anytime in the life of your father he
had an opportunity to communicate with a
braum yo PHA and lefland ow um am i
aware if my father had any time to
communicate with landau and then I'm
sorry I didn't hear the first named
Abram yo yo fell Prize winner in physics
director of Institute of Physics in
Santa Cherbourg Nobel Prize winner in
Saints st. Petersburg um I I don't know
you know there's a letter in here where
he's writing to a young cousin he he was
doing similar work to Landau in liquid
helium and he went he was asked kind of
at the last minute because because land
I was not allowed to leave the country
to attend the conference I think that he
was being honored at and so my father
was asked to step in and and lecture in
Landau shoes it's possible that there
were that there were letters in the in
the more technical files if I was
reading something and it got it got too
heavy if I saw too many equations I'm
afraid I just you know closed it up and
went to went to something else this is a
non-technical book I'm a non-technical
person so I'm
I wonder if the Caltech archives are
online and and you could maybe enter in
these gentleman's names and see if
there's something that that I missed
I loved our wife and she very highly
wrote about lefland thou opinion about
your father that's why I thought maybe
you are familiar I see Lando has written
rellenas wife his wife wrote a book
speaking very highly of my father well
it it definitely could be that there was
that there was significant technical
correspondence that that I that I passed
over I'm sorry to say Jill could you
take a moment and say say something
about your father's exploits as a
world-class safecracker ah okay um his
exploits as a world-class safecracker
well this started started during the war
his first exposure to two safes and and
what what disturbed him about the
quality of the safes was that they were
very he felt very easy and not worthy of
containing the secrets of the atomic
bomb which they did and so he was he was
interested in in showing everyone look
you know I can do it
um look how easy it is and so he would
he would pick safes and um take
documents and leave little notes you
know I mean it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't malicious you know he somebody
suggested that maybe he could have had a
career as a jewel thief and that might
have been nice but um but that was not
his that was not his thing and he he
really just wanted to prove a point that
the security was was not up to what what
it was containing um there's a there's
an ending of a letter to to his wife
Arlene which I like a lot at the time he
was just able to to do the
oh I'm thinking I'm blanking the the
regular locks the key locks and and it
was it was to be I think many months
before he could master the combination
but but he signs off saying combination
locks have me buffaloed you do too
sometimes but I love you that's very
nice one your criteria and figuring out
the letters you'd put in and second if
you have any idea what his criteria
would have been had he been around to to
help to determine what would be in a
book okay hmm
I'm sorry for all that um okay the the
criteria for for putting these letters
in was was actually fairly easy when it
came down to it um I I read a lot
the substantive letters were put aside
at the end I was working with them
the an editor from the publishing house
here in New York and and we had
extensive phone calls you know we saying
well what about this letter and what
about that letter and and we really had
very few disagreements on these things
there were letters that supported the
the themes throughout the book they were
there were more letters of uh things
that I knew like there's a series of
letters to Tina Levitan which explained
his his falling out with the Jewish
faith and and I know that that is very
consistent with his with his beliefs and
he something that he stuck with for you
know and till the day he died so I felt
very strongly about including letters
like that I think I think his criteria
well I do have to say that most of these
letters were personally drafted by him
he received much more mail than he
answered and so I think already we're
seeing his this is kind of the best of
the best if you will you know because he
only answered a certain amount and then
of that certain amount I put in most of
it so I think that's it there are things
that he indicated he learned from or
discovered in raising his children are
there things oh in this book that he
discovered that he that in the process
of raising children that he has a very
imaginative scientist wouldn't have
otherwise known but raising children yes
did he did he change his views on
education let's say by by raising his
own children and he definitely did I
mean my brother and I are diametrically
opposite you know he's he is very
interested in in science and technology
and my father told him these wonderful
stories when he was growing up of little
creatures that were crawling through
large stocks of you know blue trees and
and and it turned out to be you know you
had to use your imagination to figure
this out and it turned out to be he was
talking about these little people that
that would that would be in the carpet
and he would make up stories for Carl
now when I came along I didn't like
those stories and I was always begging
to hear the stories out of the book just
a different different personality and
and he did he did say you know it worked
making up stories worked very well on my
son but but not on my daughter so you
know he had to use it an alternate
method for that
I think hold on hello for a second
physicists were Jewish what did your
father think about that so many of the
great physicists were Jewish what did my
father think of that um well I think
preparing for his Bar Mitzvah he he had
a he had a tough time reconciling the
stories that he was learning about in in
in the school versus new the religious
stories he had a tough time putting
those together with the actual
phenomenon of nature that by this time
he was he was already old enough to
understand and you know the the rabbis
answers just didn't didn't hold water
and for him and he couldn't he couldn't
make make the jump it was it was too too
big a chasm I I think he just couldn't
couldn't believe that you know I think
it was a burning bush that that really
did it for him and um so back to
safecracking for a minute most of the
people who were at Caltech in the early
60s became fairly adept at lock-picking
thanks to your dad and I was wondering
if he passed that on to you and your
brother okay another question about
safecracking
apparently he passed on his his
knowledge to via to the folks at Caltech
the undergrads at Caltech and the
question is whether I I picked up any
skills be weird no actually I didn't I
mean I I know a little bit about it but
but no um you're probably much better at
it than I am
Michelle Mother's Day has just passed
and Father's Day is coming
how did your parents meet yes how did my
parents meet well it's it's an
interesting it's an interesting story um
she my mother was from England and she
was working her way around the the world
was her was her goal taking care of
other people's children and and she had
gotten as far as Switzerland when they
met
and she was um a beautiful woman and I
believe they met on a beach like Geneva
has a beach and she was wearing I
believe a bikini and this all impressed
my father who definitely had an eye for
for women and beautiful ones especially
so um when you know struck up a
conversation with her and um I think his
opening line was something like you know
the waters cold you know or something
and uh and they she told him what you
know what she was doing there and and he
said well you know I don't have any kids
but why don't you come to California and
take care of me and at the time he was
substantially older at 42 or something I
think and so they met the next day she
was to give him her answer and he
immediately apologized for his
impertinence because he felt you know
this is this is just not the question to
come from such from an older man to to
to a pretty young thing and but she
surprised him and I think impressed him
by accepting and and she moved out they
had to go through all kinds of Hoops to
get her out I guess
single women had to be I don't know um
what's the word sponsored thank you yes
okay and so she was sponsored and and
and came out and then when they lived
together and she took care of him he
took her to to take his to take her
driving license test and somehow they
ended up in the wrong line you know DMV
and and she ended up taking the test
with no preparation at all and and in
passed so I think this sort of set off a
light bulb to in his head they were they
were seeing other people there was no
there was no romance but he realized
just he was he was falling in love with
her and and he faulted himself for being
too impulsive so he he moved ahead went
ahead on the calendar a little bit and
and x-two off a day and
and said you know if I feel the same way
on this day I will ask her to marry me
and the day before came and he was so
excited that he couldn't couldn't sleep
he couldn't let her sleep kept her up
till midnight and asked her to marry him
okay
I really um I was wondering I in from
some of the books I read about your
father he appears that he's his father
had probably the greatest influence in
terms of his direction I'm just
wondering if he heard any stories where
your grandfather's you know into your
intellectual curiosity was centered and
you know how that relationship develop
um the question was about my my
grandfather my father's father and he he
definitely was was the force for him
becoming a scientist I mean he was
groomed from the very beginning because
my grandfather had an idea that you know
if he was a boy he would be when my
grandmother was pregnant you know if he
was a boy he would be a scientist and so
so he got his wish and and he started
out you know even even when my father
was on a high chair teaching him about
patterns with with little tiles you know
alternating white tile blue tile white
tile and then they would years later
they would take walks and the Catskill
forests and they would they would see
birds and and my grandfather who was not
a scientist and it's very interesting to
me that he had such a love for this
he was a uniform salesman my grandfather
would would know enough to say look at
that bird you know other people will
tell you the name but but that's that's
not the important thing the important
thing is to look at the behavior and you
know let's talk about that and and and I
think it was it was those early early
talks with my father that that had such
a profound effect on my father's
upbringing and just so you know my
father taught his sister his younger
sister and and I believe was was heavily
responsible for promoting the fact that
she wanted to be a scientist as well and
which she is today okay
last question
in the book you mentioned that dr.
Fineman went to your high school to
argue with your teacher so um my
question is that your teacher makes you
miserable afterwards and also I want to
ask you were you embarrassed by your
father okay that's that's yeah that's a
great question was I was I embarrassed
by my father in general um and and did I
have any serious repercussions from his
discussion with my algebra teacher I I
did actually have serious repercussions
I was kicked out of the class
my father I was not to fill you and I
was um I was doing my homework one day
innocently minding my own business and
you know how my father comes along and
says oh you want a shortcut and and of
course I said yes and and so he showed
me clever clever ways to do my homework
and um and so I got to school the next
day and were you know I was proud and um
and that the teacher just took one look
and said no no no that's that will not
do this is not what we're teaching and
if you do it like that you're going to
you're going to get a lesser score this
went on for a while and and it got to a
certain point that my father just said
you know this is enough so you went to
go see the teacher I don't think this
teacher had any idea who my dad was
and and so they you know must have had a
very awkward meeting and then finally
the teacher said you know sir let me
give you some advice you know you really
should read mathematical textbooks
and and my father you know standing up
straight just couldn't hold it anymore
and he said sir I have written math
textbooks and he left and then I'm sure
the teacher went into my counselor's
office and said who was that you know
and so she filled him in and then the
next day I was sent to her office and
you know the teacher no longer felt
comfortable with me being in the class
so so that was a little bit of a problem
since I already had a very nice schedule
but you know everything was going around
but um and and to whether my father
embarrassed me yes yes I mean I you know
maybe it's a job of all fathers um but
you know we'd be at restaurants I mean
he was just just larger-than-life he'd
he'd uh he'd make up at a party he'd
make up a language too you know if
somebody didn't speak English he'd start
you know conversing with them in in some
made-up language and you know more than
once whether it was you know people were
too polite or they just didn't know
where he was coming from but more than
one more than one occasion he was
convincing enough no one ever called him
on it
you know people people often said oh
gosh it's you know I'm I'm from the
other side of the country I guess we
just have a different dialect you know
so but restaurants restaurants I think
where it was where he really really
exercised this wonderful skill and
embarrassing me he would uh he you know
he'd leave a name and instead of leaving
some ordinary name you know he tried to
think of like the hardest one he could I
need to spell it out you know be Jay o
RK and then you know he'd kind of step
around the corner and just you know wait
gleefully hoping that they'd call it and
see what they do or um when um he'd
order coffee and then when it came you
know he'd say oh it's for the children
you know I mean purely just to see what
they do with it but I mean he was a lot
of fun he was a lot of fun I'd I have to
say I did get embarrassed by him
thank you very much Michelle Finan is
the daughter of Nobel Prize winning
physicist Richard vitamin perfectly
reasonable deviations from a beaten path
is published by basic books
the